hey everybody I'm Erik Bosse and there's
a new trailer for Marvel's Black Panther
a shorter TV spot with a lot of footage
we've seen in past trailers which I've
covered exhaustively in past breakdowns
but new interesting shots with new
insights and a new song from Kendrick
Lamar who is arranging the soundtrack
album for the film let's quickly break
down these details and of course on the
off chance I end up revealing something
accurate about this movie possible
spoilers ahead ok let's start with this
song it's hard to tell under all the
sound effects of these shots and the
exact song titles and lyrics haven't
been released yet besides the amazing
all the stars from Kendrick Lamar last
week but if you listen closely you can
hear the voices of Kendrick Lamar invent
staples rapping over an intense beat
with the possible course of cops on the
radar I hope you ready bro it sounds
like this track will be embracing those
racial themes of the music we've heard
in past trailers infusing the story of
black panther with the energy and the
attitude of current events making this
story super relevant socially-conscious
advance tickets for Black Panther just
went on sale with many theaters already
sold out so it sounds like those themes
are already connecting with audiences
okay as for the interesting new shots in
this trailer there's this one showing
black panther using his vibranium claws
to tear the door off the truck and fling
it at the soldier firing on him which
honestly seems like a bit of a fuss like
he could have just turned around and
punched the dude in the face he's
probably like Oh corridor nobody is that
before we also get more of this greeting
between T'Challa and his sister Shuri
with her jokingly bowing and saying my
king now if you look closely the
background you can see her lab assistant
he's fiddling around with this device
kind of like a touch sensitive surface
maybe operating a 3d printer to
manufacture vibranium that molecule
model looking device might be what
shapes the vibranium ative shapes that
she needs for weapons and armor there's
another fun detail in this shot that
I'll get back to later but let's move on
to this line from McCoy a the door
melash a guard who proclaims black
panther lives now from the look of the
background here this could be the same
scene where two chala confronts kil
monger among his people so it sounds
like T'Challa was thought to be dead
here but return Simba style now I just
kid not everything in Africa is Lion
King Dum Dums there's also this
interesting shot of Zuri force
Whitaker's spiritual guide character
fastening on T'Challa this Panther
warrior mask it seems that the champions
of the rival tribes wear these masks of
their corresponding animals when
sparring for control the throne of
Wakanda I actually think this mask is
part of the armor of the very first
Black Panther one of the past ancestors
of two chala like this could be a Gen 1
black panther vibranium mask worn now as
a ceremonial token meant to imbue
younger generations with strength that
may also be what kill monger is looking
at in this museum the tribal mask we see
him wearing later on a connection to his
ancestors that gives him strength but
actually in my last breakdown I pointed
out how that ring that we see kill
mugger wearing around his neck later on
on his finger looks a lot like the ring
worn by T'Challa
father to Chaka and Civil War in this
trailer kill monger says I want your
weapons your secrets it's all mine now
along with the challenge this is your
king so I'm wondering if part of this
story involves kill monger contesting
T'Challa for his birthright like maybe
he's some kind of bastard son with a
kind of reasonable claim to the throne
and maybe there's a case for it to
chacas Rea and maybe the royal titles
belonging to him as well or maybe I just
miss Game of Thrones but if valid this
question could be what leads black
panther into this spiritual journey that
we keep seeing mysterious shots of
tequila can be seen communing with these
Panther spirits ancestors who might shed
light on this literal family tree some
of you are saying this could be
depicting to Julia from the comics which
is a realm where the Libyan can commune
with the dead I've also suggested before
we could be seen the effect of the soul
stone the remaining missing infinity
stone which will probably appear some
point in black panther and it might have
the power similar to the resurrection
stone that allows the souls of the
living and deceased people to meet now I
didn't mention this before but if you
look closely at some of these characters
wrists shuri kill monger T'Challa in
previous trailers you can see these Kim
Moyo beads in the comics this bracelet
is constructed with a series of
vibranium beads a prime bead and others
with different purposes like a
communication bead bead for medical
information a navy bead with holographic
display Brian steel fries best name ever
an artist who worked on the Black
Panther comics has suggested that beads
were developed as a way to show
backstory without having to cut to a
flashback
so maybe the Black Panther movie will
similarly use these for exposition we
also get some new shots of Andy circuses
villain character ulysses klaw using his
sonic arm cannon to blast through that
korean nightclub based on is dapper
clothes here which we also see in the
shots of Klaw and CIA captivity have a
feeling this whole Busan section might
be early in the movie maybe the opening
section or something in the first act
leading to Klaus arrest and escape via
kill monger it could also explain why
we've seen so much of the action in the
scene meaning there could be even more
interesting parts of the overall story
that these trailers haven't showed us
which is very exciting
I'm also just excited to see how
colorful all this imagery is that are in
costume designer Ruthie Carter has
described in interviews how she fused
traditional African garden
patterns and colors from tribes like the
Maasai embosser II Dogon and Tuareg with
newer African styles from designers like
Eric hey Jones and Ozwald Boateng
forgive any mispronunciation of those
just trying to shout out some stuff that
we should all learn a lot more about and
again check out my breakdown to the
first - black panther trailers for
obsessive explanations of all the
footage we've seen for black panthers so
far and as we wait for the movie to come
out on february 16th a question for you
guys since buzz around black panther
seems to be growing more and more what
do you think will end up being the
biggest superhero movie of this year
Black Panther Avengers infinity war
Deadpool 2 ant-man in the or you know
one of those the first 3 now I would say
Avengers but guys I don't know Black
Panther couldn't up being the
game-changing superhero movie we've been
waiting for comment with your
predictions down below I'm curious to
know how you think 2018 will end up
going down you'd also tweet me directly
at EA boss we're probably new rock stars
on Twitter at new rock stars for updates
on our videos like this video and
subscribe to the new rock stars for more
deep dives into all the stuff you love
all the Marvel films and TV shows star
wars explainers and analyses of the
music and all this stuff and if you
really like us you can contribute to us
on patreon big thanks to all of our
donors especially Kenny Smith thanks for
watching guys this has been vas after
dark